two videos ago we asked ourselves if we
could find the basis for the column
space of a and i showed you a method of
how to do it you literally put a in
reduced row echelon form so this this
matrix r is just a reduced row echelon
form of a
and you look at its pivot columns so
this is a pivot column it has a one and
all zeros this is a pivot column one in
all zeros and the one is the leading
non-zero terminates row and this is a
pivot column let me circle them these
guys are pivot columns and this guy's a
pivot column right there and you look at
those in the reduced row echelon form of
the matrix and the corresponding columns
in the original matrix
will be your basis
so this guy
this guy so the first second and fourth
so the first second and fourth columns
d so if we call this this is a1
this is a2 and let's call this a4 this
would be a3 and this would be a5 so we
could say that
a1 a2
and a4
are a basis
a basis
for
the column span of a
and i didn't show you why two videos ago
i just said this is how you do it you
have to take it as a bit of an article
of faith now in order for these to be a
basis two things have to be true
they have to be
linearly independent and i showed you in
the very last video this the after the
second in our kind of series dealing
with this vector i showed you that by
the fact that let's say that this guy is
r1 this guy is r2 and this guy is r4
it's clear that these guys are linearly
independent they each have a one in a
unique entry and the rest of their
entries are zero so because all of the
other and this is true i'm we're looking
at three pivot columns right now but
it's true of the def if we had n pivot
columns that each pivot column would
have a one in a unique place and all of
the other pivot columns would have zero
in that entry so there's no way that the
other pivot columns with any linear
combination of the other ones could
never add up to each of them so this
these are definitely linearly
independent
and i showed in the last video that if
if we know that these are linearly
independent we do know that they are
given that r has the same null space as
a
we know that these guys have to be
linearly independent i did that in the
very last video now the next requirement
for a basis we checked this one off
is to show
is to show that a1 a2 and an
that a1
a2 an a n
that their span
equals the column space of a
now the column space of a is the span of
all five of these vectors so i had to
throw a three in there and a 5. so to
show that just these three vectors by
themselves span our column space we just
have to show that look i can represent
a3 and a5 as linear combinations of a1
a2 and a4 if i can do that then i can
then i can say well you know then these
guys are redundant these guys are
redundant then the span
the span of a1
a2
a3
a4
and a5
doesn't need
the a3 and the a5 terms that we can just
reduce it to this because these guys
these guys can be represented as linear
combinations of the other three that
these guys are redundant and if we can
get rid of them then we'll show if we
can if we can show that these guys can
be represented linear combinations the
other then we can get rid of them and
then the span of these three guys would
be the same as the span of these five
guys which is of course the definition
of the column space of a so let's see if
we can do that
so let's go back to our original our
original let me fill in so these each of
these column vectors a1 through a5 and
then each of these column vectors let me
label them r1 r2 r3 r4 and r5
now let's explore
let's explore
the null spaces again or not even the
null spaces let's just explore the
equations ax
is equal to let me write it this way
a instead of x let me write x1 x2 x3 x4
x5
is equal to 0
right that's just that's well that this
is how we define the solution set of
this all the potential x ones through x
fives or all the potential vectors x
right here that represents our null
space and then also let's explore
all of the
r
times
x1 x2 x3 x4 x5 is equal to zero this is
the zero vector in which case it would
have so you would have four entries in
this particular case would be a member
of rm
so these equations can be rewritten i
can rewrite this as
what were the column vectors of a they
were a1 a2 through a5 so i can rewrite
this as
x 1
times
a 1
plus x 2 times a 2
plus x 3 times a 3
plus x 4 times a 4
plus
x5 times a5
times a
5
is equal to 0
right that's we've learned that was from
our definition of matrix vector
multiplication and i just rewrote you
know this is just a bunch of column
vectors a1 through a5 i drew it up here
a1 through a5 and i can just rewrite
this equation like this
similarly i can rewrite this equation
as
the vector r1 times x1 or x1 times r
1
plus x2 times r2
plus x3 times r3 plus x4 times r4 plus
x5 times r
5 is equal to 0.
now we know that when we put this into
reduced row echelon form the x the x
variables that are associated with the
pivot columns are so what are the x
variables associated with the pivot
columns well the pivot columns are r1 r2
and r4 so it's r1 r2
and r4 the x variables associated with
them they call that we could call them
pivot variables
and then the ones that are not
associated with our pivot columns are
free variables so the free variables in
this case
so x3
and x5 are free variables
free
free variables and that applies to a the
so this solution set all of the sets all
of the
vectors x that satisfy this equation
also satisfy this equation and vice
versa they're the exact same null space
the exact same solution set so we can
also call
this
we can also call this x3 and this x5 as
free variables
as free variables now what does that
mean we've done multiple examples of
this
the free variables you can set them to
anything you want
so x
x 3 in this case x 3 and x 5
you can set it to any real number
you can set to anything you want set to
anything
and then from this reduce row echelon
form we express the other pivot
variables as functions of these guys
maybe x1
x1 is equal to you know a x3 plus b
x5 maybe x2 is equal to cx3
plus
dx5 and maybe x4 is equal to
e x3
plus f
x5 that's that's almost that comes
directly out of the
literally multiplying this guy times
this equals zero you would get a system
of equations that you could solve for
your pivot variables in terms of your
free variables
now given this i want to show you that
you can always you can always construct
one of your in your original vector in
your visual in your original matrix so
if we go to our original matrix you can
always construct one of the vectors that
are associated with we could call them
with the free columns you could always
construct one of the free vectors
using the linear combination of the ones
that that were associated with the pivot
columns before and how do i do that
well let's say that i want to find some
linear combination that gets me to this
free column that gets me to a3 so how
could i do that let me rearrange this
equation up here so what do i get if i
get if i subtract x2 a3 from both sides
of this top equation
i get
oh sorry that's x3a3 if i subtract x3
a3 from both sides of the equation i get
minus x3 a3 is equal to x1 a1
plus x2 a2
plus
i don't have the 3 there plus x4 a4
plus
x5
sorry x isn't a vector x5 a5 all i did
is i this this i guess salmon colored
statement here is just another rewriting
of this equation right here and all i
did is i subtracted this term right here
x3 a3 from both sides of the equation
now x3 is a free variable x we can set
it to anything we want and so is x5
so let's let's set x3 is equal to -1
so if we set x3 is equal to -1 then this
term right here becomes a 1 right
because that was minus x3 and let's set
x5 equal to 0
as x5 is equal to 0. so if x5 is equal
to 0 this term disappears and i did that
because x5 was a free variable i can set
them to anything i want
now i've written a3 as a linear
combination of i guess you could call it
my my potential basis vectors right now
or the vectors
that were associated as a1 a2 and a4
a1 a2 and a4 they're the vectors in the
original matrix that were associated
with the pivot columns
now in order to show that i can always
do this we have to show that there's
for this combination there's always sum
there's always some x1 x2 and x4 that
satisfy this well of course there's
always some x1 x2 that satisfy this we
just have to substitute our free
variables x3 is equal to -3 and x 5 is
equal to 0 into this into these
equations that we get from our system
when we did it with the reduced row
echelon form so you get you know i mean
you don't i don't know if i even have to
go to u in this case you get x 1 equal
to minus a plus 0 x 2 is equal to minus
c so on and so forth so you can always
do that you can get your you can get you
can always express the vectors
you can always express the vectors that
are associated with the non-pivot
columns as linear combinations of the
vectors that are associated with the
pivot columns what i just did for
a3 you could just as easily have done
for a5 by subtracting this term from
both sides of the equation setting x5 to
negative 1 and setting x3 to 0 so that
the 3 term disappears and you could
run the same exact argument
so given that i've hopefully shown you
or at least helped you see or or made
you comfortable with the idea that the
vectors
let me do them in a nice vibrant color
these magenta color vectors here
that are associated with the
free columns
that are associated with the free
columns or with the free variables right
the free variables were x3 and x5 x3 and
x5 and those were these columns right
here that they can always be expressed
as linear combinations of the other
columns because you just have to
manipulate this equation
set set the coefficient for whatever
you're trying to find a linear
combination for equal to minus one and
set all the other free variables equal
to zero that you're not solving for and
then you can get a linear combination of
the
of the
of the vectors that are associated with
the pivot columns so given that we've
shown you that look these three
vectors and i'm using my terminology
very loosely but these ones that are
associated with the non-pivot columns
can be expressed as linear combinations
of these guys
so they're unnecessary the span of this
is equivalent to the span of this the
span of this is the column
space of a so the span of this is the
column space of a so the last video i
showed you that these guys are linearly
independent and now i show you the span
of these guys is a column space of a so
now you should be satisfied that these
vectors that are associated let me do it
in a blue color that that vector
that that column vector
this column vector and this column
vector that are associated with the
pivot columns in the reduced row echelon
form of the matrix in
do indeed
represent a basis for the column space
of a anyway hopefully you didn't find
that too convoluted